[Music]
top five defensive tackle prospects as
identified by chris sims last week on
unbuttoned and it was a close call at
the top chris what'd you do flip a coin
throw a dart light a match what'd you do
well i just went with the guy that i
thought was just a hair more disruptive
than the other but derek brown javon ken
law mike i mean it's 1a 1b
it doesn't matter it really doesn't mike
these are both top five talents in the
nfl draft like if quinn and williams was
a top five pick last year than these two
are as well i mean they're bigger than
quinn and williams they're every bit as
athletic you know they had that factor
mic of where i watched games and i went
wait am i watching the highlight film or
is this the game you know so to me
they're very intriguing and with the tua
quarterback injury conversation and him
falling out of the top five and probably
not going to be good trade bait
i do look at those two as being hot
commodities to where if i'm the lions or
giants i'm hoping teams fight over those
two guys right there and come up and
make a move and try to get them
does the fact that quinn and williams
got so much hype last year and some were
saying he's even a safer pick than a
nick bosa some may have been you and me
uh does that in any way
take some of the some of the the shine
off of the top defensive tackles issue
does that carry over at all
i i don't think so i mean i understand
there's probably some trepidation there
but they're a little bit different guys
you know quinn and williams last year
you know 305 310 these guys are 326 330
and dominant and a little more versatile
and i think what they can do mike they
could be pure nose tackles and just make
a mosh pit of the offensive line in the
run game they also can be guys that you
could just say
hey get on the edge of the garden win
that gap and create havoc and they can
do that or they could be a three-four
defensive end mike where they got to
hold up guys and read you know offensive
tackle read in the backfield okay the
running back's going this way let me
throw my guy that way and go make the
tackle but
without a doubt top five commodities
these guys i was just couldn't be more
impressed really with the defensive
tackle group it's pretty impressive mike
i think there's gonna be
i really think you have a chance to have
five defensive tackles go in the first
round maybe not maybe six i really think
it's a position that's being a little
overlooked in this first round scheme
right now
and the problem always is the defensive
tackles were thrown into the mix with
everyone else who plays every other
position so you start calling names the
defensive tackles can be overlooked
where do you see your top two guys going
in the top ten
well i think if i look at the top ten i
mean when you look at seven eight and
nine right i think those three teams
between the panthers the cardinals and
then the jaguars they have needs at
those positions and i would think if
those guys are sitting there when
they're coming up to pick i don't know
how you could turn them down i don't you
know those are guys where you go wow
they're gonna make a difference for my
football team from day one and then
gonna be here for a long long time and
really have you know
huge huge ceilings so they're they're
really impressive mike i think they're
can't miss prospects that's how good
they are and i would be shocked that
they were not picked in the top ten
if only the f up the play were an
official statistic we'd have greater
appreciation for their talents because
it sounds like based on how you're
describing them wherever you put them on
the offensive or defensive line
that's
what they're going to have a high
potential of doing
definitely they they can do it all mike
they're really and that's that's the
beauty of them is i don't think there's
any scheme that they're going to look at
these players and go oh they don't fit
our scheme you know they're so big so
talented so athletic so strong at the
point of attack that i think every
team's gonna look at them some might
look at them a little differently oh
we'd like to play them here we'd like to
play them there but either way
they're gonna be somebody that defenses
defensive coaches and head coaches gonna
look at and go oh he can play in our
defensive line we'll find a spot for him
let's go forward and just let them
dominate really impressive like i said
top five talents be shocked if they get
outside the top 10.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports